- As I mentioned at the top of the show,
Erin and I are due for a rematch
of the game we played last time,
which the game is Tic Tac Toe,
and I know how to play,
- You are fibbing how this went down
- No, I did not
- Yes you did
- No, I forgot.
- No, I'm telling you, I forgot
God's honest truth. I forgot
we were playing Tic Tac Toe
- Gosh
= Let's see the highlights reel, Erin.
- Boy
[Kelly Laughs]
[Upbeat Music]
Okay, I had to take my
shoes off 'cause it's real,
- Fine, sorry Mika, I'm doing it too
I'm not gonna-- my shoes are done.
- [Lord] Okay, I understand
- I'm excited
- [Lord] What NFL team has only
a single Super Bowl victory?
(Bell rings)
- Eagles, Final answer
- [Lord] What is the name
of the Duke men's basketball coach?
- Coach K (bell rings)
- [Lord] In what year
did the Atlanta Braves
most recently win the World Series?
- Oh my God
- '96
- Clarkson, you're a graduate
(buzzer) - '96
- [Lord] I'm sorry that
is incorrect. (crowd ahs)
The answer was 1995.
- [Erin] I think I win!
- Oh what!
(Congratulatory sound)
(Whoops)
(Winners music)
- Loser! Loser!
(Crowd cheers and claps)
(Kelly laughs and claps)
The ladies are back
(crowd cheers and claps)
This is Trisha, Ava, and Allie.
Um, are you guys ashamed
of your performance?
- I'm ashamed of your performance.
- Yours.
(Laughing)
- Tic Tac Toe
- We showed up.
- [Kelly] Kelly] Y'all
have-- you have no idea
- Tic Tac Toe
- I got shamed.
(laughing) So bad, in my house,
anyone, are y'all ready to do this?
- Yes
- Let's go
- Okay, I know we're playing Tic Tac Toe
- Be proud by the way you guys are here.
I didn't get to bring any of my friends.
- Because you're Erin Andrews.\
- I would have brought Troy Aikmen, David
= Oh, what ever!
(laughing) Whatever! You know things.
- You would have won
- And I believe that this is crap.
- Holy God, whatever!
Whatever, it's real this time,
I know what game we're playing. It's on!
- Oh Lord
- Erin's a sports pro.
- No I'm not
- And I-- yes you are,
comparatively speaking.
- That's so wrong
- [Kelly] Comparatively Speaking.
Is it wrong you killed
us last time? (laughs)
- You have 4 against 1.
I'm gonna take off my shoes now too.
- You-- I've got my shoes on, ma'am
- Kelly!
- I'm so ready!
(Crowd cheers)
So ready.
- Let's go!
- I am sports ignorant.
You are sports pro, I'm sports ignorant.
So I was able to get an
assist from sports ball posse.
My si-- last time we had
we had my sister Lisa,
um, and my friends Trisha, Allie and Ava.
Um, even with all that
help - 'cause they suck.
Um, I did not win! (laughing)
It might've been me.
Um, but I've got Ava, Allie
and Trisha back with me,
in person now. (crowd cheers)
And it's time to play another round of
the balls of sports games.
(Erin sighs)
♪♪the ball of sports♪♪
Alright, shoes off.
Heart ready, Tic Tac Toe.
We're gonna need a host.
- There is so much trash talking.
I want to throw a ball.
This is crazy.
- Lord, are you there?
- [Lord] I am Kelly, I was
just busy watching Bridgerton
by myself. (laughing)
If you know what I mean.
- Get it Lord,
- You know what I'm talking about.
You know girl, I'm surprised
you want to play this again
'cause, uh, it didn't go
well last time fo' ya'.
Now did it?
- I-- try, try again.
That's what they say.
- Uh huh, uh huh, now let me
tell you the rules here now.
In this game, you win by
getting 3 squares in a row
on that big board. Just like Tic Tac Toe.
- That, did you hear it?
- You know to get you
familiar with the game.
Okay, good. Okay
- 3 in a row, 3 in a row.
Got this.
- [Lord] Now, to win a square,
you throw a sports ball
through the matching sports square,
and then, you'll get a
question about that sport.
Now if you get it right,
you gonna win the square,
but if you get it wrong,
the other person will win the square.
Pick a square
- Okay, the football.
- And you get to go first.
- Okay, I'm gonna-- yes.
- [Lord] mhm
- This is my show Erin.
- - That's true, good point.
- Okay, here we go. Here we go.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Oh, (beep).
- Oh
Wait wait. Where? Where? Where?
Where? Where'd it go? Where'd it go?
(laughing)
- [Lord] That's the way to do it, Kelly.
That's it. There ya go.
- [Erin} There You Go.
- [Lord] Alright, now,
here's your question.
- Wait, wait, hold on.
- Yeah?
- Just so I understand the rules.
- [Lord] Uh huh?
= She can't like steal, right?
I can go right away, like it's just us.
- [Lord] This is just you right now,
but if you get it wrong, she goin' take it
away from you
- Okay,
- [Lord] So be careful, here you go.
- Okay
- [Lord] In American football, a touchdown
is worth how many points?
- Oh! Six.
- Six
- [Lord] That is correct.
- I knew that one. (bell rings)
- [Lord] And you get the square.
(laughing and clapping)
Okay, now, Erin, it's your
turn. Now, you goin'--
You goin to pick a ball and--
- Don't be distracted--
Throw it in the corresponding square.
- By my win, Erin.
- I'm just blown away , you
have 3 people to talk to.
- Here's the thing, that I
did know that answer though.
- Uh huh
- And then, no, and then
you go for extra points.
For the field goal.
Or for the, for the, that
one thing where they pass.
- I don't know anything about dodgeball.
- [Lord] Okay, well that's too bad.
'Cause you about to get a question.
(Laughing)
In the movie Dodgeball,
what fictitious cable sports
channel broadcast the games?
- [Ava] I know this. I
know this. I know this.
- I don't.
- I know this.
- I don't know.
- [Kelly] I don't either.
- [Lord] You don't know the answer?
- Can I have your friend?
- You can-- (laughs)
- [Lord] Okay, well then.
- [Ava] I know it.
- [Lord] That is incorrect, so Kelly,
now you--
- Ava
- ESPN The Ocho.
- ESPN The-- The Ocho.
- Yes
- Come on
- [Lord] That is correct. (bell rings)
And you get the square.
You have stolen the square.
Unbelievable. Look out, now. Look out.
- Totally knew that, dude.
- [Lord] And, Kelly, you are
now up. It is time for you
- And I-- because I know
we're playing Tic Tac Toe.
- [Lord] That's correct.
- I'm going to pick, tennis.
- [Lord] Oh, very good.
She's gettin' it, folks. She's getting it.
- [Erin] I am surprised you
didn't pick up the softball.
- [Lord] There it is. (crowd clapping)
- Okay
- [Lord] Okay, here is your question.
- (sighs) Oh.
- [Lord] Who defeated tennis player,
Bobby Riggs in the famous
battle of the sexes?
- Oh, I met her, but the shoes.
- Billy Jean King
- Yeah
- Yeah, Billy Jean King. I have her shoes.
- [Lord] Billy king jean
is correct. (bell rings)
(cheering and clapping)
You've done it. (hip-hop horn)
- Look, I'ma pass-- I'ma
win one, I'ma do one.
- Can I hit you?
- I just wanted to try one.
I just want to make one.
(Erin whoops) (Laughing)
I can't do anything sports wise.
- [Lord] This show is
completely out of control.
(Laughing)
- Here's the thing. I think we
won fairly, and it was even.
- Everything about this was so fair.
- It was an-- it was an even win.
- This was great.
- Thank you so much!
Erin, that was so fun.
(Crowd cheering)
- That was a blast.